uncle iro is a complex figure as a
general he waged war with legendary
skill
yet as avatar the last airbender
concludes he's become a mild-mannered
tea shop owner
here's the full backstory of general iro
though beware of spoilers if you haven't
seen the show
iro was born into the fire nation royal
family the firstborn son of fire lord
azulon
from the day he was born he was heir to
the throne of the imperialist nation
and for a while he lived up to its
bloodthirsty ideals
ira was born to a world already at war
decades removed from fire lord sozen's
genocide of the air nomads
as such ira was immersed in the fire
nation's propaganda from a very young
age
as aang would encounter himself in a
fire nation school
iro learned that the fire nation was
civilizing the world by bringing its
greatness to the farthest reaches of the
globe
while he was always possessed of a
casual demeanor and frequently balked at
his younger brother ozai's naked
aggression
ira dutifully followed through on what
was expected of him
he became an incredibly talented
firebender and joined the army
eager to prove his prowess iro had
become a legend by the time he marched
on bossing say
the capital of the earth nation in
addition to his accomplishments on the
battlefield
he'd become known as the dragon of the
west as he was widely believed to have
slain the last living dragon
although iro had secretly let the
dragons he encountered live
his renown was such that no one had
reason to doubt his story
thus he was entrusted to lead the siege
of bossing say
iro led his forces to the city's outer
wall and began a siege that lasted for
600 days
ira was in fact able to breach the
city's outer walls
and lead his troops into the city's
farming district
however the breach came at a terrible
cost
iro's only son liu ten was killed by
earth kingdom forces
devastated ira ordered a retreat ending
the siege for good
ira's power-hungry younger brother ozai
saw an opportunity in ira's tragedy
ozai met with their father fire lord
azulon
and argued that he should be made next
in line for the throne
you must have realized as i have
that with liuten gone iron's bloodline
has ended
azzulon was so offended by his son's
lack of compassion
that he ordered ozai to kill his own
firstborn son
zuko so that he might know ira's pain
to protect zuko ozai's wife ursa hatched
a plan to kill a zulon
and place ozai on the throne after it
was carried out
she was banished for treason ozai became
firelord
and iro accepted his new role without a
fight rather than return to a capital
where he no longer was needed
ira traveled the world in search of
greater meaning he returned to the fire
nation
a changed man only to find his nephew
walking the same violent path
he himself had once traveled raised to
believe in the never-ending glory of the
fire nation
and desperate for his father ozai's
approval zuko refused to learn from
ira's new philosophy
he saw his uncle as an old fool someone
who had quit on the fire nation out of
personal weakness
to zuko obsessed with proving himself
worthy against his brilliant younger
sister
iro represented his greatest
insecurities
despite this iro held a soft spot for
the young prince
doting on him as if he were his own son
foolishly iro caved to the pre-teen
prince's request to sit in on a war
council with the fire lord and his
generals
there zuko spoke out against a
particularly bloody battle plan
that hinged upon the intentional
sacrifice of fire nation battalions
to pay for his insult fire lord ozai
demanded his son engage in an agni kai
a traditional fire nation duel believing
that he was going to face the general
zuko eagerly agreed to the match when he
arrived in the dueling arena however
he was shocked to find his father facing
him
zuko might have criticized the general
but by doing so in fire lord ozai's war
room
he had most grievously insulted his
father
terrified the prince refused to fight
ozai viewed this as further disrespect
branding his son a coward before burning
his face
and banishing him from the fire nation
ozai told zuko that he could return to
the fire nation
on one condition that he find and
capture the long-lost avatar
iro grasping the sheer cruelty of his
brother's actions
offered to go along to help his nephew
on this seemingly impossible quest
iro spent the next several years urging
zuko to cool his heels
rightfully noting that zuko had the rest
of his life to search for the avatar
you know prince zuko destiny is
a funny thing you never know how things
are going to work out
iro and zuko did eventually find the
avatar in the south pole
where he had been trapped in ice for 100
years
as the avatar fled to the northern water
tribe in order to find a water bending
teacher
zuko and iro followed close behind
however they weren't the only ones
another fire nation soldier admiral zhao
was also looking to nab the avatar
himself
zhao and prince zuko had clashed several
times
with neither one gaining the upper hand
eventually
zhao attempted to assassinate zuko but
zuko was able to escape
and stowed away on zhao's ship iro aware
of zuko's arrival played the bereaved
uncle and traveled with zhao to the
northern water tribe
during the attack on the north however
zhao very nearly threw the entire world
into chaos
we killed the mortal embodiment of the
moon spirit as waterbenders
become more powerful at night when they
are aided by the moon
zhao decided that destroying the moon
spirit would end this advantage forever
believing that zhao had doomed the world
iro attacked him and his crew
still a warrior of legendary skill iro
was able to incapacitate
all of zhao's soldiers though the moon
spirit was restored by the actions of
princess ue
and the fire nation forces were turned
back by a massive show of angst power
word spread of ira's attack upon his own
countrymen
this made iro and zuko fugitives from
the fire nation
iro and zuko rid themselves of
identifying clothes and insignia
even shearing away their traditional
top-notch
dressed like earth kingdom civilians
hiding their fire-bending abilities
the pair traveled across the countryside
incognito
unfortunately beyond the fact that he
was a fugitive from the world's most
powerful army
ira was being personally tracked by his
terrifying and methodical niece azula
the heir to the fire nation throne was a
sadist
and she inherited her father's cunning
and ambitious personality
in a fight with azula and the avatar
zuko was very nearly beaten
iro stepped in between his niece and
nephew and was badly wounded before team
avatar and zuko worked together to repel
azula's attack
ultimately iro and zuko settled inside
the city of bosingsei
the very same metropolis that iro failed
to capture years before
they were able to sneak into the heavily
guarded city using
fake passports that iro procured via his
membership in the order of the white
lotus
a secret society that ignored the
divisions of the four nations
embossing say iro and zuko began working
in a tea shop
where iro quickly gained renown for his
exceptional tea brewing skills
though the life satisfied iro zuko
became increasingly upset by what he saw
as their stagnation
he wanted to get back to hunting the
avatar which was he still believed
the only way to restore his honor zuko
did cross
paths with the avatar embossing sei
nearly stealing uppa
aang sky bison in order to lure him into
a trap
but ultimately he let appa go after
talking with iro
you never think these things through
this is exactly what happened when you
captured the avatar at the north pole
you had him and then you had nowhere to
go
at last zuko was beginning to understand
that honor was not something to be
bestowed upon him by his father
but equality to determine on his own
unfortunately
zuko's sister azula managed to track
down zuko iro
and the avatar in bossing say well aware
of her brother's insecurities she
tempted zuko into attacking the avatar
with the promise of their father's love
a temptation zuko could not ignore as
zuko fought alongside his sister
iro fought against his niece and nephew
allowing team avatar the time to make
their escape
the fire nation received both siblings
back with celebration
the avatar was presumed dead bossing say
had finally fallen to the fire nation
and iro the traitor was behind bars
but ira wasn't out of ideas locked away
he began a workout regime that would
allow him to escape
he also nudged zuko who furtively
visited his uncle in an attempt to
assuage his own guilt
into studying his own ancestry slowly
zuko pieced together the complex history
of his country
and the truth of his own destiny as a
peacemaker
newly buff iro managed to break out of
prison
at the same time zuko having finally
realized his rightful place at the
avatar's side
became aang's fire-bending master the
end of the war drew closer
eventually bringing zuko and iro back
together again
zuko was overcome with shame as he
begged his uncle to forgive him
but as ira made clear there was nothing
to forgive
i was never angry with you
i was sad because i was afraid you lost
your way
freed of his father's expectations zuko
had at last become the young man his
uncle had always known he could become
when zuko suggested his uncle become
firelord however
iro refused such an act he argued
would be seen as yet another ambitious
power grab in a family history filled
with them
instead he suggested zuko take up the
mantle
providing a peaceful path forward for
the fire nation
as aang set off to face ozai and zuko
traveled to the fire nation capital to
duel his sister
iro and the other members of the order
of the white lotus gathered in a camp
outside bossing say
at last iro broke into the walled city
but as a liberator
instead of a conqueror following his
nephew's coronation
iro remained in bossing say there he
owned and operated the jasmine dragon
the city's finest tea shop after the war
iro settled into his more peaceful life
as zuko worked on setting the world
to rights though he frequently wanted
the advice of his longtime mentor
zuko felt it was best to leave iro alone
his uncle had finally attained the
peaceful life he'd spent decades
striving for
and zuko felt that bringing iro back
into the politics of the fire nation
would be selfish
however zuko taking the entirety of the
fire lord mantle on himself
did not sit well with the still young
ruler he exhausted himself
and was brought to iro to recover iro
schooled his nephew on how stubborn and
foolish he was being
telling zuko that he would always be
welcome in his uncle's home
no matter his reason for calling zuko
eventually called in that favor to an
extreme degree
when zuko set out to find his long-lost
mother he asked iro to serve as
interim fire lord in his stead fittingly
ira's first action as firelord was
instituting a nationwide
tea appreciation day he would continue
to help zuko throughout his reign
serving as a decoy for the fire lord
when secret societies plotted against
the new leader
and acting as a fire nation envoy when
the homeland was too hectic for zuko to
feel comfortable leaving his royal seat
eventually iro made the decision to
leave the world behind
and ascended to the spirit plane where
he promptly set up a tea shop
there avatar korra the next incarnation
of the avatar encountered iro while she
was lost on a trip through a dark forest
much like he had done for his nephew iro
helped guide the young avatar through
her more complicated emotions
when korra was at a low point and unsure
of what to do
ira appeared again and explained that
the avatar is not all-knowing
just because she is a symbol of the
world in harmony that didn't mean
korra was a god even when he was no
longer on the mortal plane
ira remained a wise mentor to those who
needed him sharing tea
with a fascinating stranger is one of
life's
true delights check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one